[Music]
today
thursday in the afternoon the 16th of
the month of december of the year 1610
at six o'clock was when perhaps as many
as 19 people
from japan in china arrived and entered
here in the city of mexico
[Music]
noble their lord the ambassador from the
court of the great
ruler of the emperor of japan who
brought them
came to make peace with the christians
so that they would never make war but
always be at peace and
esteem each other so that spanish
merchants will be able to enter japan
and
none of the people there will be able to
impede them
and likewise the people of japan will be
able to come and enter mexico here
to do business to come here to sell
their goods that are made there and
no one will be able to impede them for
thus the lord viceroy
don luis de velasco marquis of salinas
for whom they came to see
informed them
don rodrigo de vivero brought them here
they all landed together he had
gone to be governor of the city of
manila in china and was the nephew of
the ruler
don luis de velasco marquis viceroy in
mexico
this said don rodrigo de vavero had
gotten lost on the ocean as he was
coming here to mexico as
became known today it turns out
that a sea storm arose over them in the
ocean
and they went along driven by the winds
of the storm
and they threw all their goods they were
bringing in the water and in that
condition the storm carried them
to where they landed in the great royal
altipetal
of japan
[Music]
where the people of japan met them in
peace the ruler the emperor
in japan and don rodrigo met together
it became known that he went to reside
at his palace he
made much of him fed him and there don
rodrigo borrowed from the emperor in
japan
and because of that don rodrigo came
bringing many
people of japan
and some of the said people of japan who
came here were already christians
and some still idolaters who were not
yet baptized
and they came dressed as they are
dressed up there they
wear something like an ornamental jacket
doublet or long blouse which they tie at
their middle
their waist where they place a katana of
metal which counts as their sword and
they wear
something like a mantilla and their
footwear is soft
softened leather called chamois
sort of like foot gloves that they put
on their feet
they seem bold not gentle and meek
people going about like eagles and their
foreheads are very bare because they
closely shave their foreheads making the
shaving of their foreheads reach to the
middle of their heads
their hair just begins at their temples
all going around
towards the nape of their necks the hair
is rather long
they look like girls because of the way
they wear their hair
they put it together into something like
a piochley
which they tie in twisted intertwined
fashion reaching to the middle of their
head with close shaving
it really looks like a ton sure that
they display on their heads
and they don't have beards and they have
faces like
women and they are whitish and light
with
whitish or yellowish faces all the
people of japan are like that
that is how their corporal aspect is
and they're not very tall as everyone
saw them
when they entered mexico here the noble
men from there who came
appointed as the leader of the japan
people was greatly honored
the carriage of the viceroy his very own
property
went to chapel tepec to meet him as he
was passing by on the road
he sent to him sitting in the couch
together a
discal said friar whom he had brought
from japan and the judge of the
audiencia
today sunday at two o'clock on the 23rd
of the month of january of the year
1611 was when the church of san
francisco were baptized
two of the japanese people who came they
were baptized with true
splendor it was done in the presence of
all the different ecclesiastics who
dwell in mexico
who all appeared there the first
baptized was a noble and
lord of japan whose name upon baptism
became
don alonso don hernando alte morano then
captain of the guard became his
godfather
lorenzo became the name of the second
japanese person baptized
don pedro alto mourinho became his
godfather
and right away on the next day on monday
again a japanese person was baptized
felipe became his name
today monday the 7th of the month of
march in the year 1611
was when sebastian viscaino citizen of
mexico
set out and left mexico going to china
at that time he then took the japanese
he placed next to himself the japanese
nobleman whose name was now
don alonso and who now went dressed as a
spaniard
to return to his home here he threw away
his outfit that he wore coming here
he was the only one to change his
clothing here in mexico
they had been here in mexico just two
months
when 17 of them returned home three
stayed here in mexico
today tuesday the 4th of the month of
march of the year 1614
was when again they arrived here and
entered into the city of mexico
those japanese nobles they came in on
horseback at 12 o'clock
noon their vassals came ahead of them
just coming on foot
holding high something like little
long narrow black poles maybe their
lances perhaps that signifies royal
leadership there in japan
they came retired just the same way they
go about and are retired back home
they wear something like a tunic tied in
the back
and they tie their hair at the backs of
their necks
so far only 20 of them have reached
mexico here
they're left behind still coming along
the way the lordly emissary the
ambassador
sent here by the great ruler the emperor
in japan
who is still coming at his leisure
bringing a hundred of his japanese
vessels
one of our fathers comes interpreting
for them
this is the second time that the
japanese have landed one of their ships
on the shores of acapulco
they are transporting here everything of
iron and
writing desks and some cloth that they
are to sell here
on the said japanese ship came also
senor sebastian viscayno
a spaniard citizen of mexico who had
gone to japan to
look around since he had taken back the
other group of japanese who would come
from there three years ago now
the said senor sebastian viscayno is
also still coming
slowly coming hurt the japanese injured
him when they beat and stabbed him at
acapulco as
became known here in mexico
today wednesday the 9th of the month of
april of the year 1614
was when at the church of san francisco
20 japanese were baptized
[Music]
you